if I want to say oh I want to build this
Corporation and she's going to say good
luck or say well what's the first couple
steps there's a different type of
mentality of women and then when I say
when I reference Beyonce I'm not talking
about her star power I'm talking about
how she can look at a corporation or a
business and say you want to own title
Jay-Z well this is what we're gonna do I
know a couple of artists we can bring
them here and work with you to actually
become that massive male masculine
figure that's the type of woman that I
believe in this Nevada day generation is
outshined I would say at this moment of
time so it's not like oh it's not
realistic no there are women out here in
this world but you just have to you're
not going to find them